le pied gris c'est le nom local du
sauvignon donc il est aussi reconnu en
tant que Sauvignon rose ou Sauvignon
gris la bouteille n'est pas la plus
connue des cavistes et c'est ce qui fait
toute sa valeur elle provient d'un
cépage originaire du centre Val de Loire
mentionné dans l'oeuvre de rabelet au
16e siècle devenu marginal au fil du
temps la variété a frôlé la disparition
elle est aujourd'hui mise à l'honneur à
l'occasion d'une séance de dégustation
consacrée au cépage rare on a quelque
chose de beaucoup moins dans la vivacité
C'est on est vraiment sur quelque chose
de un côté un peu agrume c'est
très original
entouré d'enfants en Indre-et-Loire et
dans le Loir-et-Cher en 18 c'est très
surprenant ce que c'est très c'est très
parfumé moi je sens une fleur d'oranger
très fort on n'a pas forcément
l'habitude
qu'on peut dire parfois sur des vieux
cépages de voir qu'on connaît pas de
vieux cépages dénichés par ce caviste il
a participé à des recherches menées en
partenariat avec l'Université de Tours
on travaille sur des livres anciens sur
des sources historiques et puis comme on
dit souvent plus on cherche plus on
trouve et donc en ayant des noms de ces
pages qui existaient avant on arrive à
tracer un fil et il existe un
conservatoire national dans le sud de la
France à vassal près de Montpellier et
on demande à sortir certains cépages qui
sont là-bas
les cépages rares traversent la France
et sont acheminés jusqu'en Touraine sur
cette parcelle 6 variétés ont été
plantées il y a deux ans elles sont
entretenues par les bénévoles d'une
association de sauvegarde du patrimoine
fruitiers local grâce à leur ancienne t
certaines variétés pourraient se montrer
plus durable que d'autres face au
réchauffement climatique ces variétés
c'était là il y a très longtemps donc
elles ont déjà connu historiquement des
périodes caniculaires et puis des mini
périodes de glaciaires donc elles se
sont un peu structurées ce sont
défendues par rapport à ces événements
climatiques des analyses vont être
réalisés sur ces cépages pour mesurer
leur vitesse de développement certains
seront implantés chez des vignerons à
titre d'expérimentation la
commercialisation du vin produit sera
alors à l'étude au total la procédure
pourrait durer entre 5 et 10 ans